avec la menace terroriste cette rentrée
2016 ne sera pas comme les autres pour
les 500 mille lycéens d'île de france le
30 août le conseil régional a annoncé
les évolutions attendues dans les lycées
budget prévu pour ces changements plus
de 660 millions d'euros 10 millions
seront consacrés à sécuriser les
bâtiments un montant doublé par rapport
à 2015 ça va nous permettre de réaliser
dans 130 clichés des opérations de
sécurisation alors scellé clôture à
l'entrée c'est de la vidéoprotection
s'est dessiné des signaux d'alarmé
etc etc ça correspond à des demandes des
lycées pour faire face évidemment aux
risques auxquels ils sont soumis
nouveauté cette année l'expérimentation
d'un budget d'autonomie pour douze
lycées publics franciliens
une enveloppe de 780 mille euros est
mise en place dans les yvelines deux
établissements testeront ce dispositif
objectif donner plus de souplesse c'est
permettre aux équipes éducatives de
faire vraiment leur choix pour leur
lycée ils ont besoin de langues vivantes
supplémentaire ils ont besoin de cours
de soutien supplémentaires ils veulent
faire une spécialité sur le numérique
ils veulent faire une spécialité
internationale ils peuvent choisir la
région entend aussi lutter contre la
radicalisation en organisant des
conférences animées par des témoins du
terrorisme de parents de victimes de
mohamed merah ont accepté de participer
différentes actions culturelles seront
programmés pour favoriser l'ouverture
d'esprit on veut faire entrer plus de
culture avec plus d'éducation artistique
dans les lycées d'île de france parce
que je crois que la culture c'est la
réponse à la barbarie et c'est aussi un
outil extraordinairement fort de
cohésion nationale depuis 2013 le nombre
de jeunes en décrochage scolaire stagne
aux alentours de 30 mille l'île de
france souhaite renforcer les actions de
prévention
valérie pécresse prévoit d'organiser des
assises du décrochage scolaire avec le
corps enseignant et des associations
les discussions devraient se tenir fin
septembre